[Musica]
mi presento come un insegnante precaria
ma il fatto di essere precari non
implica che uno non possa portare un
programma un progetto educativo
importante anzi tutt'altro
il fatto di essere pregare sono una
condizione lavorativa ma non è il modo
con cui poi uno lavora e fa il suo
lavoro
allora
18 questo mi sono trovata circa dieci
anni fa più o meno a a dover rimettere
in gioco la mia vita perché capita a
tutti di dover fare i conti con il
propria piece con la sofferenza e quindi
avere il coraggio poi e mediare con
questa sofferenza per mettersi in gioco
ma veramente difficile però si aprono
scenari nuovi scenari che spesso ecco
come è stato per virginia
magari si arriva a fare delle cose
grandi io invece ho fatto soltanto una
piccola riflessione ho immaginato di
vivere la mia vita in modo più autentico
e che vuol dire questo vuol dire fare
del quotidiano delle piccole cose
ecco anche fare l'insegnante bregaglia
in modo straordinario dare valore e
significato alla propria vita in modo
tale che ogni cosa possa diventare un
evento bello di cui meravigliarsi di cui
stupirsi ogni giorno
allora ho deciso di riprendere gli studi
mi sarebbe bastato anche il mio vecchio
isaf e per entrare a scuola
oddio entrare al quale è difficile tanto
che sono di esami che faccio la precaria
però ho deciso di riprendere a studiare
e mentre prendo questa decisione
berlino la possibilità di partecipare ad
un progetto per la scuola primaria che
guardate causa nella scuola primaria non
è previsto l'insegnante di scienze
motorie
però io proprio perché credo
nell'insegnamento credo nel valore e nel
rispetto soprattutto delle nuove
generazioni dei ragazzi
accetto questa sfida che poi accetto io
come molti altri e per cinque anni porta
avanti questo progetto cinque anni
meravigliosi dove ho imparato le lezioni
fondamentali la prima è stata data
direttamente dai bambini
ogni insegnante secondo me dovrebbe
avere come maestri di vita proprio i
bambini
loro sono spontanee giocano e un
insegnante di scienze motorie dovrebbe
guardare giocare papini perché loro
attraverso il gioco insegnano
un'infinita ti portano nel loro ma ti
dicono noi abbiamo bisogno di questo
guardaci l'altra purtroppo e lo dico una
consapevolezza ma anche con tristezza è
che nella scuola primaria
l'insegnante di canto e motoria come
insegnante di scienze motorie bambini
l'attività che farebbero dalla mattina
alla sera
andassero a scuola è quella di giocare e
quindi cominci a fare delle riflessioni
sì quando apre in una scuola così nelle
classi e più piccini vi assicuro che i
bambini quando vedono un insegnante
aperta a quello che fanno
ti farebbero anche un salto mortale
ma dico così loro sarebbero capaci di
fare qualunque cosa per un insegnante
che presta attenzione al loro modo di
porsi alla vita
e allora quella l'attenzione che
meriterebbero questi bambini
l'attenzione di portarli almeno in
palestra nelle due ore che comunque sono
previste nell'orario curricolare invece
spesso quelle due ore vengono scambiate
per quasi un ricatto allora ragazzi si
va in palestra solo se vi comportate
bene mi raccomando prima facciamo
lezione sechi e poi andiamo in palestra
oppure oggi non si va in palestra vi
siete comportati male come possiamo
considerare l'ora di scienze motorie
chiamatela come volete adesso si chiama
scienze motorie e sportive quell'ora
importantissima per i nostri ragazzi
alla stregua giuramento esclusivamente
di stato sicuramente un momento
divertente ma perché perché i bambini si
divertono ma mentre si fanno anche
esperienza un'esperienza diretta del
voto si sperimentano si mettono in
relazione con gli altri sono creativi e
mentre sono creativi loro sì grano e il
crearsi significa formarci svilupparsi
crescere ma non dovrebbe fare questo la
scuola invece noi costringiamo troppo
spesso i nostri ragazzi a stare seduti
ore ore e ad ascoltare la lezione così
non diventa un insegnamento
significativo perché un bravo insegnante
ha delle competenze altissime capire
tante cose ma di tutto il sapere che io
dovrei trasmettere ai ragazzi che cosa
arriva loro se non sono loro che si
fanno artefici del proprio sapere
e allora io credo che laddove
l'istituzione non stampe la nostra
istituzione preveda le ore di scienze
motorie ma laddove non è stata così ci
si fa la differenza la potrebbero fare
il corpo insegnanti in un dialogo
reciproco
si parla molto di
interdisciplinarietà ma quanti sanno che
in palestra che l'insegnante di scienze
motorie aprire un dialogo a 360 gradi
con tutte le altre discipline e nonna
interromperle ma amplificarle
amplificare delle modalità perché in
palestra si mettono in pratica tutte le
metodologie che un bravo insegnante
dovrebbe conoscere quel palestra e
adesso
saliamo un pochino nei gradi superiori
abbiamo alla scuola secondaria di
piccola the dalla scuola secondaria di
secondo grado le medie alle superiori
quando andiamo in palestra
i ragazzi sono costretti ad imparare
facendo questa imparare facendo che cosa
idrica implica che devono trovarsi di
fronte alla situazione l'abbiamo
risolvere
dica che fanno che interagiscono tra di
loro quindi il lavoro di nuovo il lavoro
dai rappare imparare reciprocamente
dall'azione che fa il compagno
l'avversario se si fa un gioco di
squadra quindi
le scienze motorie devo avere una
prerogativa importante non essere messe
in secondo piano
avere una visibilità e una interazione
con le altre materie davvero di primaria
importanza perché permette in qualche
modo di sviluppare quelle che sono le
competenze che poi direttamente o
trasversalmente un ragazzo può spendere
nelle altre discipline
accanto a questa mancanza di attenzione
delle scienze motorie
c'è un altro grosso problema che viene
da sé è il problema che non riconosciamo
il valore dello sport e dei ragazzi che
fanno sport e qui devo portare la mia
esperienza diretta
io per dieci anni ho anche seguito un
gruppo di ragazzi di atletica quindi li
ho presi da piccolini e poi piano piano
siamo cresciuti siamo cresciuti sono
cresciuti loro sono cresciuti e vi
assicuro che nessuno gli ha fatto lo
sforzo
quest'anno forse le ultime due tre hanno
fatto la la maturità e sono stati
ragazzi però perché so che lo sport fa
anche questo sviluppa competenze
trasversali a 360 gradi
sono ragazzi che sono usciti dal
scientifico prendendo il massimo dei
voti minimo ha avuto 95 forse 100 100 e
lode perché questo perché questi ragazzi
ai quali spesso gli viene rifiutato un
diritto e un riconoscimento importante
di quelle che sono le attività che fanno
all'esperto e la scuola se ne
acquisiscono da soli le competenze la
sporta fa anche questo
i ragazzi hanno dovuto organizzare un
lavoro e chi fa sport e sa bene che il
programma prevede almeno tre allenamenti
per cominciare ma quasi casa 45 il fine
settimana chi fa sport e di squadra a a
negare chi fa sport e individuali come
la pratica dei momenti importanti nei
quali ha le gare che sono guarda caso
proprio il momento che coincide col
primo quadrimestre il secondo
quadrimestre carabine dell'atto eppure
questi ragazzi da soli organizzate
e l'anno galletta totalmente bene che
riescono più pene nel nello studio
allora perché non riconoscere il valore
a allo sport il valore peculiare che la
di formare i nostri ragazzi di dare loro
delle competenze a 360 gradi
competenze che li metti che mettono il
ragazzo in relazione con gli altri che
gli fanno capire il valore del successo
ma più ancora della sconfitta perché il
successo vedere qualche volta si è bello
arrivare lì al podio ma poi per certi
aspetti finisce lì invece quando il
ragazzo perde più bravi e percy già a
rialzarsi il valore
nell'altro
che è qualcosa che ci mette e ci fa
incontrare gli altri come diceva anche
il professore già nello sport si
realizzano tantissime di quelle
metodologie che dovrebbero essere al
centro di un per conservativo e
formativo lo sport apre dialoghi apre le
frontiere apre la mente lo sport forgia
il carattere lo rafforza
fa tirare fuori una capacità di
resilienza elevatissima che non troviamo
in nessun altro abito ma perché questo
perché lo sport è il movimento hanno
questa questa prerogativa così peculiare
perché sono le attività che l'ataf ha
per sua natura l'uomo sarà stando fermo
non si è voluto perché stava fermo si è
voluto e che era in movimento perchè
sperimentava gli spazi correva le
distanze ha imparato in questo modo
pensate poi se la matematica e torno
all'interdisciplinarietà venisse
insegnata in palestra ai bambini anziché
a scuola mettersi lì allora le
cappelline pariamo le lady state pensate
se rifacessimo citare a scuola grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]